the mets hall of fame class 2021 now
officially inducted ron darling john
matlack and edgardo alfonso
congratulations
again to al jackson and his family as
well the late great al jackson for the
mets hall of fame achievement award
tommy baez taking the field as a met for
the first time at city field he'll be
playing shortstop and batting cleanup
well there's rich hills numbers he had
the one start
prior
five days ago
is eight enough
you can hear some booze coming down for
joey botto
2-2 on the way and the curve ball
bounced down to first alonso corrals it
and that retires the side wade miley his
numbers now coming off a little bit of a
rough outing for miley
there's a hot shot to suarez who handles
with a plum
routine to india
well this is vintage weight mining
3-2 coming and the curve ball breaks his
back pops it up and baez with his first
chance as a met handles it flawlessly
and suarez goes down swinging on another
high fastball and hill's got his first
strike out of the night
and the curveball flicked on the ground
easy play for baez he throws out
barnhart and baez will lead off to the
match in the bottom of the second how do
you buy as all business as he gets ready
for his first at bat as a mets
first pitch
farmer on the lower bound fluid field
and throw
weak ground ball suarez
palar could fly tag by bottle nice
adjustment by the veteran first baseman
[Music]
breaking ball to first the lobzo no
cover and shougo akiyama is on
just his fourth hit since the all-star
break yeah that's the eilee squares and
buns foul again behind home plate strike
three so miley strikes out rich hill as
fan two akiyama's running and the
curveball in for a call third strike
mccann into second vote strike him out
throw him out double play
drury dalts one into right center for a
base hit that's going to go to the gap
and back to the wall and the raging hot
brandon drury
delivers the matt's first hit of the
night an opposite field double
corners are in looking for the bun
and hill pushes the tour third nicely
done my was going to have to hurry and
he gets it there in time
if you didn't have a 41 year old running
to first base who might have beaten that
out reds have their infield in as vr
bats he grounded to suarez his first
time
and then swinging on three and oh he
dunks one into left for a base in and
the mets will get the first run of the
game
a broken bat 3-0 hit for vr
brings home drury and it's one nothing
new york
ball in grounded a farmer feeds into one
on the first in time double play
oh two pitch
winker swings and misses strike three
rich hill overpowered jesse winker
farmer hits an eight straight
extra base hits in three in a row it's
the longest hit streak of his career and
he goes out to get that breaking ball
shoots it into center field
reds have their second hit of the game
as suarez had that huge home run season
a couple of years ago
suarez
cracks it deep left field hey eugenio
suarez to the mid deck
a three-run jack and the reds lead
three to one
his 20th home run of the season
[Applause]
akiyama
dom smith lays out and gets past him
pilar on the backhand to sprint over to
third by barnhart
and akiyama up to second base the reds
in business with two in scoring position
three two coming
and miley strokes one the other way don
coming on diving
oh wow
tom smith saving two runs
farmer has extended his hit streak to
nine games
kyle farmer hammers a breaking ball deep
left field a career year for kyle farmer
two out solo shot a four
one reds lead as farmer rewrites his
career highs with his tenth home run
the o2 on the way swung on and missed
strike three and the ncd strikes out his
first batter
1-1 hit on the ground slowly to the
right side baez has it throws to first
in time side retired well perez
and that's all four so a four pitch walk
to vr to start the sixth alonzo who
liked vr swung into 3-0 pitches last
time up
and pete rifles one to left field winker
or
playing on a hop
winker did not get a good read on that
ball he was
short stepping it all the way
and alonso's got to base in and the mets
will get the tying run to back
daylight play at second throw down the
tag they got it all they are caught
napping oh wow
[Applause]
mcneil the outfield was attached shallow
wicker extends on the run and makes the
catch
alonzo was already at second a great
sprinting track down by jesse winker to
rob mcneil bias is grounded de short and
struck out in his first two at bats as a
met alonzo at first and two out and bias
gets one in the air left field
[Applause]
a towering shot his first home run as a
new york bank coming in his first game
for the mets
and bias gets the mets right back in and
it's 4-3
[Applause]
fly ball out
miley with the lead and seth lugo is on
to face
kyle farmer
and he likes to sink it a lot and how
about farmer taking it the other way and
picking up three hits on the night
he entered with home runs in seven
straight games
joey bottle clubs it to right
off the tippy top of the wall
farmer broke and got all the way to
third base the reds team
they know it in the dugout vato came
that close
[Applause]
and he struck him out went further up
the ladder to get naquin for the first
down of the inning
and he gets suarez looking for the
second out
2-2 coming and he picks them off bottom
caught between first and second now
they've got the runner hung up between
third and home
and now
vr
running farther toward the plate mccann
puts on the tag and the side is retired
wow
[Applause]
2-2 from may and akiyama goes down on
the inside fastball
and that's the first out
one two from may to freeman
and he struck him out high heat from
trevor may and he's got back-to-back
strikeouts two down
and india pops it up bae is taking
charge of it
[Applause]
oh
very tired of the side again the 3-2 to
mcneal
and he walked in
and now three you know when it gets away
from stevenson and giorni goes to second
and he falls it into stevenson's glove
strike three a big k for henry
swinging
back-to-back haze for henry
the left-handed veteran sean doolittle
is on looking for his
113th career c
here is smith now the army tying run at
second two out last of the ninth four
three reds and dom lines what's
happening
here comes the orb
he will score the time run
the next down to their final strike don
smith with
[Applause]
down gets away from nato india breaks
for third boy diaz could really use a
strikeout and he gets it
struck him out
high heat from diaz
line center field but right at pillar
side retired
delar is the free runner at second
brandon drury will get the first crack
at driving him in with the winning run
and he pokes one the other way base hey
killer the third is being waved around
weaker with the throne of the plate
hillary scores in the midst win it
brandon drury with a walk-off hit and
the mets win it in 10-5-4
[Applause]